ترتفع تكاليف المعيشه في فرنسا بسبب
التضخم ارتفاع يبدو ملحوظا في اسعار
المواد الغذائيه وصل في بعض الاحيان الى
40 في المئه وفرض خيارات صعبه على
المواطنين من بين تلك الخيارات ان الاسر
اصبحت تستغني عن بعض المنتجات او تلجا الى
منتجات اقل جوده وذلك من اجل الاقتصاد في
المصروف مواد الغذائيه
كل جزء اكبر حدود 25 خلينا نقول 25 30
على زياده اسعارهم لان الموردين رفعوا
اسعار المنتجات عليهم وهذا تسبب بتداعيات
مباشره على حجم مبيعاتهم
ل بعض المنتجات لا يمكننا السيطره على
ارتفاع اسعارها ولذلك اجبرنا على رفع
اسعارنا بنحو 50% وخفض الكميات بيانات
المعهد الوطنيه للاحصاء والدراسات في
فرنسا اظهرت تراجع الانفاق الاستهلاكي
بنحو اثنين فاصل ثمانيه في المئه في شهر
اكتوبر الماضي تراجع تعزه الحكومه الى
سياق تاثر بالحرب في اوكرانيا وما سببته
من زياده في اسعار الطاقه
العربيه باريس